y el secretario de estado de eeuu
anthony blinken aseguró que el grupo
talibán en podría permitir evacuaciones
después de la fecha límite del 31 de
agosto
contradiciendo al presidente joe biden
mientras miles de personas siguen
llegando al aeropuerto de kabul para
intentar escapar del régimen talibán que
ahora controla el país
en brasil miles de indígenas esperan a
las afueras de la sede del tribunal
supremo- la histórica decisión para los
pueblos aborígenes que responde a una
apelación del desalojo de justamente
fuerzas ancestrales una reserva natural
como reporte de brasilia
y la onu pide a la comunidad
internacional casi 190 millones de
dólares para asistir a los 800 mil
damnificados por el terremoto de
magnitud 7,2 que golpeó haití y dejó más
de 2.200 víctimas fatales la entrega de
ayuda se ha visto obstaculizada por
daños en las vías terrestres y por la
presencia de grupos criminales
continuamos con más información de
américa latina y del mundo aquí en atrás
24 mi nombre es liliana valencia
iniciamos en afganistán a información
encontrada sobre la fecha límite de
evacuación el secretario de estado de
eeuu o antony blinken aseguró que unos
1500 estadounidenses estarían esperando
para salir de territorio afgano por lo
que cree que podría completarse antes
del 31 de agosto fecha límite acordada
con el grupo talibán sin embargo también
dijo que espera que permitan la salida
de los estadounidenses y afganos que
quieran abandonar el país después de
dicha fecha
marina sardiña nos cuenta más en este
informe miles de afganos esperan en
precarias condiciones poder subirse a
uno de los aviones mientras observan
desesperados como la fecha límite de las
repatriaciones está cada vez más próxima
en el aeropuerto de kabul una botella de
agua se vende por 40 dólares un plato de
arroz por 100 dólares dólares no afganos
sino estadounidenses eso está fuera de
alcance de la gente común dólar de agua
ni de eeuu reiteró su intención de
cumplir con la retirada total de sus
tropas del 31 de agosto esperan que el
grupo talibán cumpla con su frágil
compromiso de permitir que los civiles
puedan abandonar afganistán después de
su salida
desde mi perspectiva y la del presidente
estos esfuerzos no terminarán el 31 de
agosto continuará durante todo el tiempo
que sea necesario para sacar de
afganistán a las personas que deseen
marcharse were tweet desde las
peticiones de la comunidad internacional
y de algunos demócratas del presidente
joe biden se mantiene firme en su
decisión según la casa blanca washington
ha ayudado a evacuar a más de 80.000
personas de la capital afgana pero
todavía no están claros los
procedimientos de asilo para los miles
de demandantes una vez sean reubicados
una vez las personas lleguen a eeuu
serán elegibles para solicitar asilo u
otras vías de inmigración disponibles
que tengan como condición procesos de
selección servicios y procedimientos
adicionales entonces no no podemos
garantizar nada a nadie le animo a
nanita
de una situación en la que podrían
rechazar algunas de estas solicitudes de
asilo y enviarlas de regreso a
afganistán no anticipó que ese sea el
plan o durante una entrevista con el
medio español del país jens stoltengerd
secretario general de la otra declaró
que la misión de las tropas
internacionales durante la invasión
estadounidense era proteger a eeuu y no
a afganistán
el primer ministro de israel
bernat talibanes está en su primera
visita estatal en washington desde que
asumió el cargo en junio pasado primero
adelantó una cita con el secretario de
estado- anthony blinken y mañana se
encontrará con el presidente turbay de
en su intento de líder israelí de
reiniciar las relaciones con eeuu luego
de algunas tensiones cuando el partido
demócrata llegó a la casa blanca a la
salida de donald trump quien tenía con
quien tenía una buena relación con su
antecesor benjamín netanyahu
vamos ahora a brasil porque hay
expectativa por la decisión del tribunal
supremo sobre uno de los casos más
representativos frente a los derechos
territoriales de los pueblos indígenas
la discusión gira en torno a la ley
promovida por el gobierno de jair
bolsonaro que luego aprobó la cámara de
diputados y que propone que se
reconozcan como tierras indígenas
solamente aquellas donde ya vivían por
los originarios desde antes de la
constitución de
1988 bienes indígenas dicen que la
medida viola sus derechos y desconoce la
historia de expulsiones que han padecido
desde épocas de la colonización y hasta
la actualidad
previamente hablamos con nuestra
corresponsal y brasilia gabriella
antúnes quien nos entregó los detalles
de esta información
todavía no llegó el momento que pueden
respirar tranquilos los 6000 indígenas y
un campamento viniendo a 170 pueblos
distintos en brasilia hoy a la espera de
un juicio para los indígenas choclán es
la causa daría seguridad jurídica a
todas las tierras indígenas todas las
reservas del país por eso los pueblos
originarios del país están acá esperando
que la suprema corte decida sobre esta
causa para dormir tranquilos y que para
no avance el plan del agronegocio
brasileño sobre las tierras indígenas
brasileñas para que los planes del
gobierno bolsonaro de explotación
financiera y económica de zonas de
reservas indígenas no avancen y estas
tierras quieren desmarcadas por un marco
legal que les daría mucho más seguridad
y el supremo tribunal federal no logró
llegar hasta el juicio manteniendo en la
agenda otros juicios paralelos la
expectativa es para mañana que retomen
el juicio y que llegue una decisión que
dé a estos pueblos originaron un marco
legal para la demarcación de tierras
indígenas en el país
al menos 16 personas han muerto en el
occidental estado venezolano de mérida a
causa de las intensas lluvias que han
provocado deslizamientos de tierra y
ríos o desbordados
autoridades regionales informaron que
más de 1200 casas han sido destruidas 17
personas han desaparecido y todavía
permanecen en un paradero desconocido
entretanto los equipos de rescate siguen
buscando sobrevivientes y registrando
las zonas afectadas 80 bomberos y 60
oficiales de protección civil han sido
desplegados en la zona para socorrer a
los damnificados
organización de naciones unidas pidió
casi 190 millones de dólares a la
comunidad internacional para ayudar a
los afectados del terremoto en haití y
es que las necesidades de la población
se exacerbaron después del sismo del 14
de agosto antes de esa fecha y sólo en
el 3 departamentos del país más de 6000
personas tenían necesidades agudas hoy
son más de 800 mil
sin comida ni vivienda antes de la
tragedia más de 6 mil 100 personas en
los tres departamentos más afectados por
este sismo ya tenían necesidades
humanitarias agudas de las que 3.500
sufrían necesidades extremas el
terremoto lo exacerbó sobre todo para
los más vulnerables como las mujeres
sufrimos no tenemos acceso a los baños
nacionales en vez de no podemos orinar
todo el mundo te está mirando
necesitamos espacios suficientes para
lavarnos
es difícil lavarse incluso a última hora
de la tarde se moldea capsat como vesta
guerrier otros 200 damnificados viven en
el campamento de cambio en donde las
mujeres se enfrentan a precarias
condiciones tengo tres hijos hemos
estado sentados aquí bajo las sábanas
desde el sábado no podemos ir a casa
porque nuestra casa está destruida no
tenemos ningún lado donde vivir además
el terremoto acabó con gran parte de la
infraestructura miles de viviendas
hospitales y escuelas quedaron en ruinas
ya antes del terremoto había 44 millones
de personas que padecían inseguridad
alimentaria en haití eso se ha agravado
y agravado aún más por el terremoto así
que la comida es imperativa mucho más de
lo que era antes según la oficina de
naciones unidas para la coordinación de
asuntos humanitarios se necesitan 187
puntos 3 millones de dólares para
atender las necesidades básicas de los
afectados por el sismo que dejó
alrededor de 2.200 muertos y 12.000
heridos
el residente ruso vladimir putin sostuvo
una reunión virtual con su homólogo
chino xi jinping en conmemoración del
duodécimo aniversario del tratado de
buena vecindad y cooperación amistosa
entre ambos países xi jinping aseguró
que china y rusia deben explorar nuevas
formas de cooperación para lograr
mejores resultados por su parte putin
dijo que rusia apoya la política de una
sola china y se opone a cualquier fuerza
externa que interfiera en los asuntos
internos del gigante asiático
y finalizamos hablando de la legendaria
agrupación de música rock nirvana porque
el hombre que apareció desnudo cuando
era un bebé en la portada del álbum
nevermind en 1991 presentó una demanda
contra los integrantes sobrevivientes de
la agrupación el hombre alega que la
imagen constituye un caso de explotación
sexual infantil en una demanda
presentada en un tribunal federal de
california
spencer elden alegó que había sufrido
daños de por vida por la imagen
utilizada en la portada de dicho álbum
en el recreo con la imagen cuando ya era
adulto en 2016 tiene actuado el
nevermind en su pecho
así finalizamos contenido ustedes con
base para el 24 punto com
[Música]